We have a special emphasis on
the unique challenges that women face.
When they try to negotiate, when they try
to manage teams, when they try to lead.
>> Some people find it very
difficult to be authoritative,
even when the roll calls for that.
Some people find it very difficult
to ever deffer to anyone.
There's a lot of research that
indicates that women just don't
choose to negotiate in
circumstances where men do.
And this has tremendous implications.
[MUSIC]
I try to expand their expectations
about what is negotiation
beyond an adversarial
win-lose kind of dynamic.
We have them negotiate, and
I use their results as the basis for
the discussion for developing a framework
for how can they be more effective.
>> What we deal with in this course
is understanding the psychology
that gets in the way of
feeling comfortable.
The opportunity to step back and
think in a more big picture kind of
way about our goals, our aspirations.
The extent to which we contribute
to the bottom line in our company.
>> One thing that came to my mind
during this last week was this whole
idea about power.
The power in silence,
the power in not acting.
>> The thing that both Debby and Maggie
always retreated one knows these things.
It's just a matter of seeing it
from a different perspective.
I would recommend this program
just to have a confirmation,
is your leadership style okay?
Do you need to make any improvements?
>> We provide them with specific
strategies for dealing with the problems
that they face, and they're like,
I wish I'd had this years ago.
This has transformed how I
think about this problem.
>> And it's very cool when faculty members
hear that we have transformed your lives.
It's kind of like, yes,
this is what we're here for.
[MUSIC]